you answer mine it's actually not my job
to answer your questions are you
prepared to call h a terror group is it
possible to have a rational I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on P Morgan on sense of the
bombshell Royal Revelations the whole
world is talking about my decision last
night to name the two Royals at the
center of the alleged racism storm has
divided opinion across the globe tonight
we'll debate why I did it also debate
omed sco's rampant Li
and we'll debate whether there's any
truth behind those in my view entirely
baseless allegations of
[Music]
racism live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to Pi
Morgan uncensored two and a half years
ago the dukee and Duchess of Sussex sat
down with Oprah Winfrey to air a slew of
Grievances and claims about the roal
family that they had deserted the most
incendiary claim was that members of the
royal family had raised quotes concerns
in multiple conversations about what
skin color baby Archie skin would
be and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's
born what
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like hold up hold up there there
are several conversations there's a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look
like and you're not going to tell me who
had the
conversation I think that would be very
damaging to them okay compartmentalized
concerned that if he were to
Brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that I wasn't able to follow
up with why but that if that's the
Assumption you're making I think that
feels like a pretty safe one you see
that's just an allegation of racism
right there it's not ambiguous that is
Megan marle accusing a member of the
roal family of being racist judging
somebody according to the color of their
skin and how Brown they are there's no
room for thinking it's anything else
now the impact of that claim was
extraordinary the claims were reported
breathlessly across the world tens of
millions of people hundreds of millions
were left with the unavoidable
impression that Britain is a racist
country with races at the heart of our
royal family but just the fact that
there is according to both of them this
ongoing blatant racism not only in the
UK tabloid press but in the family but
for some people in this country a
blanket to denial of racism like the one
that we heard from Prince William
yesterday just isn't enough
Buckingham racism among the more
shocking revelations was that of sort of
overt racism she faced within the royal
family but here it is a couple that's
truly in love and the thing that you
want to question is their skin tone I
hope all those people are having severe
second thoughts or buyers remorse about
believing what Megan marle and Prince
Harry said I don't need to because that
day I said I didn't believe a word of it
and I had to leave my job because I
didn't believe them even though I think
they were lying well for two and a half
years there's been frenzy speculation
about how who these supposedly racist
Royals are just about every single
member of the royal household has been
implicated in the rumors at some point
and that surely isn't fair is it just
guilt by Collective
Association especially if you believe as
I do as I've always said that the claims
in my opinion are completely and utterly
baseless that speculation reached fever
pitch again this week because of his
weasly lick spitt omed scobby he's the
client journalist of the sussexes he's
always the first to publish their Soviet
Style official statements and defend
their indefensible deeds he's like that
guy comical allei do you remember him
who fronted up for Saddam Hussein in the
Iraq War and would literally say we've
got him on the run as American howt say
were coming over his head well Mega
marle famously denied briefing scobby
for his last book Finding freedom but
then she was forced a few months after
it came out to apologize in court and
admit that actually she had she briefed
one of her aids to go and tell scobby
all the L all the laundry so when it
emerged that the L's book contain new
details on those race accusations well
let's just say I've made my own
assumptions about where scobby could
have got that information from because
it wasn't King
Charles so that only leaves the other
person on the end of that correspondence
that's Megan Markle or maybe Harry her
husband or maybe one of their mutual
friends the scobby keeps boasting he has
scobby says he knew the names of the
accused Royals but couldn't use them for
legal reasons that's in the English
version of his book then as everybody
now knows the names suddenly appeared in
a Dutch translation of the book and by
appear I mean they were sent to
journalists who couldn't believe what
they were reading they went into
bookstores where people could buy it
well last night I decided this was all
ridiculous and it was time to name the
two rules implicated in those racism
claims they are as I said last night
King Charles Prince Charles as he was
then and Catherine Princess of Wales I
did that for several reasons first the
speculation was once again raging out of
control as it has for two and a half
years second it made no sense that Dutch
journalists and Dutch people who bought
copies for the publisher withdrew them
would know these names members of our
royal family when the British people
were prevented from knowing them thirdly
once you know the names it becomes
blindingly obvious to anyone with even
half a brain that these allegations are
ridiculous whatever your view of the
monarchy I don't think any serious
person really believes that anything
they've seen or heard from King char or
the Princess of Wales suggest they have
even the tiniest racist bone in their
bodies or would judge anybody according
to the shade of their skin and once
again it's worth remembering what Prince
Harry eventually said about these
accusations when he was promoting his
book and before we play the clip just to
remind you after launching This Racist
bombshell two and a half years ago it
never got mentioned again not in the
six-part Netflix series which mentioned
everything else in their lives not in
the 12-part podcast for Spotify that
Megan marle did never mentioned and it
never got mentioned in Harry's over 400
page book 150,000 words of stuff about
his entire life but not a mention of the
supposed racism by members of his own
family which he had launched as a
missile against that family on Oprah
Winfrey so this is what he said to Tom
bradby at I n at the start of this year
when promoting the book where he didn't
mention
it in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well the British press said
that right I did did Megan ever mention
they they
racist she said there were troubling
comments about concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially raac I wouldn't not
having lived within that family God he's
such a dim wit isn't he he's just dim
ditchwater he literally thinks we're
going to watch the clips back from Oprah
and not think that she was saying that
the Roy family had been racist how dumb
does he think we
are so Harry performs this dramatic
U-turn oh it was never we never meant to
suggest they were racist it was the
terrible British press they were the
ones who said it was racism we just
meant unconscious bias you know what
that's become a euphemism for we
actually haven't got any evidence of
someone being racist we just think it's
kind of unconscious on the sly right
it's kind of there but we can't prove it
it's like we think they might be yeah
not good enough not when it comes to
members of the royal family whose
reputations are on a global
stage so why should I stand back and let
a proven liar like omed scobby a man who
claims in this book as a fact that I
have regular phone chats with Queen
Camilla regular do you know how many
times I've spoken to Queen Camilla on
the phone in my entire 58-year life
zero not
once it's not just not regular it's
never
happened we've never had a phone
chat so he's a liar and he lied again
about when apparently I called Mega
michael princess Pinocchio on that
fateful last day good Morning Britain
apparently camiller immediately
contacted me to thank me on behalf of
the firm no she didn't another lie
complete
liee so SC be prepared to lie about me
about these little things which don't
really amount amount to a row of beans
why should we believe anything else he
has to say all he's doing is dragging
the whole royal family through the mud
all over again reigniting these racism
charges because he wants to sell books
and make money well SC gave another
interview this morning two this morning
in which he again denied working with
mean Markle and he also denied ever
using the names in any draft of his
book I'm as frustrated as everyone else
I make it very clear in this book that I
in every way possible want to adhere to
the laws surrounding this subject it's
why I've been very careful in how it's
described in the book and it's why I've
never spoken about it
beyond what I've said in the public
domain before the realityy is though is
that this is information that is not
privy just to
me a liar a barefaced liar he wants us
to believe that he only submitted a
draft in the English version which never
mentioned the names but that somebody in
the Netherlands got hold of it and added
the names and added entire paragraph in
one part of this into the manuscript
before it went to the printers a lethal
sabur who would do that you ever ever
met any author in history because I
haven't who's had that happen to their
manuscript the on the way to the
printers in a foreign country like the
Netherlands they got into the manuscript
and changed it without the author
knowing anything about it no it doesn't
pass what we call the smell test it's
disob stinks when it comes to the smell
test now he thinks I'm completely wrong
to assume an earlier version of his book
included the names and acept for
translation only for his lawyers to take
them out of the final addition which I
think is the most likely explanation
it's therefore rather inconvenient for
him the Dutch translator has told
reporters tonight that she'd only
translated what was written down on the
manuscript she said the names of the
Royals were there in black and white I
didn't add them I just did what I was
paid to do and that was translate the
book from English into Dutch now at this
point the deafening Silence from Harry
and Megan becomes a little more than
deafening it becomes pretty shameful
because they usually race to condemn and
denounce any press reports that we
dislike particularly if it involves any
leaks from private correspondents Mega
marle ironically was forced to admit
that she colluded with omis scobby on
his last book in a court action she took
against a newspaper over private
correspondence with her father so why
have they remained So Silent about omis
sco's lies and also about his leaking of
the private correspondence between Mega
marle and King Charles that contain
these names is it because
they were involved in him getting this
information is it because I don't know
the tooth Theory came down and did it or
Santa Claus or for want of a better a
better third example
Pinocchio the public can of course make
their own minds up about all of this it
shouldn't take a long and the same goes
for the baseless accusations of Royal
racism nobody I repeat really thinks
King Charles or the Princess of Wales
are
racist nobody that's part of the reason
actually why I decided to put their
names out there it's called Lancing the
boil it's called removing what has been
a simmering threat deployed by Megan and
Harry and deployed by om scobby as an
unspoken threat we've got these names
and if we if we don't get what we want
we're going to use them well now they
can't do that I've been at the sharp end
of British Jour for 30 years I've seen
World crises come and go remember after
Diana died everybody predicted that was
the end of the monarchy but it wasn't
the monarchy survived and it thrived
with our great Queen Elizabeth the
second and is doing so again now with
King Charles he's doing a brilliant job
as the head of our great royal family
and the head of the great monarchy the
only crisis I think that we're facing at
the moment this end game as omis scobby
puts it is an end game for omed scobby
and potentially depending on how they
respond to this to the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex because this morning the Times
newspaper the paper of record in this
country the paper read by opinion
formers politicians those who matter
said that it was time that King Charles
removed the Royal titles from a couple
who seem to want to destroy the royal
family in the monarchy but
simultaneously make millions and
millions of dollars by trading off their
Royal titles from an institution they
keep trashing that may well be the
beginning of the end game for their
Royal
duplicity okay let's get into a debate
about this um I'm joined Now by Tera
Dunlop by Dicky Arbiter by Paul Lon
Adrien and by Paul Burl who of course
was the butler to Princess D let me
start with you Paul you're up up there
in Chesire your response to all this and
in particular start with my decision to
name Charles and Kate last
night I think the British public have a
right
to know which members of our royal
family are being Trashed by the sussexes
or their court on the other side of the
Atlantic and if the if the information
did come from them and I can't think of
anyone else it could have come from um
then you know we should know and we
should we should put up our defenses and
defend our royal family because Kate has
never put a foot wrong and King Charles
is doing a great job and the shadows of
his mother who who was impossible to
follow so you know I I think you're
right Piers I do I I think we have a
right to know and to defend both our
King and our future Queen okay Tessa
Dunlop you've been seething away quietly
to my left I can see you simmering to
simmer
away you P me peers occasionally I think
no he's found the light he's seen the
light he's no longer crashing on about
Harry and then this appalling dir tribe
we've just had to sit through you
claiming you lying there suggesting that
you're putting their names out
effectively to save the Mony you put
their names out for clicks you're no
better than omed scobby in fact you're
worse you call him a li spittle you're a
great big go of Flem that's just landed
on the Royal doormat I don't know how
you slept last night I struggled to
sleep thinking about what You' done I
really and yes I did I did know that's
you suggest that stop the perform crap
it's performative crap no let's just
hold on to calm down have civilized
conversation idea you didn't sleep over
this you don't even know these people I
was no I was properly angry by your
hypocrisy and then the hypocrisy because
you spend day in day out your pro
monarchy the wonderful Queen wonderful
Charles and then you go and do Kate and
Charles right in it when On's at 28 did
wait a
minute I'll tell you who did that Omid
scobby because these names appeared in a
draft of his book which was published in
the Netherlands they were under the line
to Netherlands tit tattle to you popped
it on a muroc platform and now you've
just had the goal to suggest you're on
platform right now I know I am problem
with that correcting the record for the
record that was pe's highly dubious
opinion I've got a problem with you
tonight peers a real problem why would
you have a problem with a being on a
murd platform because what you did was
you put those names you're being paid to
appear yes I know but you took the name
the rumor the rumor and you put it on an
official platform you turned it from
fiction why you accepted money from a
murder to challenge you about your
behavior and hypocracy and by the way
just the word baseless how do you know
that Megan's rumors were baseless how do
you know what she accused any of but
where's the evidence that was baseless
where well obviously it's very difficult
when the two accusers of the chief
witness couldn't even decide on Oprah
Winfrey what year these supposed
conversations had happened or how many
there were right they couldn't decide
what year doesn't mean it didn't happen
you take notes and write in your diary
happen really let me get a Dicky I I
just want to come in you you mentioned
the Oprah interview and quite frankly
Megan said that it happened the
conversation happened when she was
pregnant about 10 minutes later Harry
came into the interview and said it
happened before they were married so
when did it happen and did it happen and
there's a big question mark I will take
issue with you naming yesterday and I
made that point point this morning um
you are a bit of a law on to yourself
worse than a law excuse me I didn't
interrupt you actually just on the law
point it was entirely lawful what I did
so I did seek legal advice I got very
good sound legal advice and actually
there's no question I didn't take the
law onto myself I actually applied a
letter of the law this information had
been published in the Netherlands Dutch
people were free to read it and I took a
view it was ridiculous the British
people couldn't be aware of this
information I also said when I named
them that I didn't believe a word of the
racist allegations made against them I
didn't either I didn't either didn't
believe anything of that that that
interview it was just a dire tribe of
absolute nonsense as is the book endgame
and as you rightly say endgame the only
person endgame is is scobby but I did
take isue in in mentioning him last
night yes you have say the Brits have a
right to know uh it's in the Dutch uh
translation
but there are those who will say agree
with you there were those who disagree
with you well many of the papers who've
held off apparently tonight are going to
name you gave them no choice you always
got a choice sorry you always have a
choice everybody's got a choice everyone
has a choice everyone had a choice when
it was published in the Netherlands not
to repeat the names right if they're all
going to repeat them tonight in the
papers they were just a day after us
right and I have a show called
uncensored for a reason I don't believe
in self-censorship I don't believe when
the Dutch people can read this
information in a book available in
bookstores as some of them had already
bought copies that British people should
be denied that information
and the information by the way is hugely
significant we've waited two and a half
years to find out who these members of
the royal family were that Mega Mark
weird people like session PE waiting no
no actually the entire country has no
that's a misrepresentation of most of
the country what I actually want to know
is he said he had no help from the Sues
and yet on the other hand he said he saw
the letters yeah so how did he see the
letters how has he got the information
exactly it's not got it from King
Charles it's all come from monito right
Paula thank you you wow okay so you're
going to be shocked at this but I
actually agree with you that you named
that you identified them yesterday and
let me explain to you why because
everybody in the Royal Circle knew who
it was all the Royal journalists knew
who it was I've spoken to people who
knew who it was the fact that they've
been named didn't come as a surprise to
me because it's fairly common knowledge
among journalists I don't think many
journalists knew about Princess of Wales
I think they thought it was another
member of the royal but you
accept well I was actually surprised but
I was not surprised that again it made
it even more to me obvious that this is
all complete bull crap exactly and
that's where you and I actually agree on
this because the the the fact that it
was they they were named in the
Netherlands it is almost neither here
nor there the fact is there are people
here who knew and you're right the
British people did have a right to know
who it was and now we know who it is
what's going to happen next well surely
action needs to be taken and here's
where I am am disappointed with you I'm
disappointed with you because we had a
monologue of you berating and throwing
disdain at uh at Megan at Harry at Omid
talking as if you have spoken to King
Charles talking as if you have spoken um
to Kate spoken as if you have spoken to
Camila but you haven't and so if you
haven't everything that you have said is
based on assumption and I think you did
accept and I think you did accept
actually and and everyone no no no no no
because you actually used the word
assumptions in what you were saying you
are also making very D you are also
making very dangerous assumptions and
what you have done this evening is you
have set anybody back who is suffering
from racism of forward because you are
suggesting suggesting that because of
what somebody RIS and because of their
role in society that you cannot
challenge them that is what you have
said this even and that is dangerous do
matter put back racis it doesn't matter
who it is I tell you who's put back
racism people cry wolf about racism I
don't know if they're CRI they're
despicable CRI I've been assured assured
who by who never you mind oh come on
you're not going to your sources and
I've been assured
the let name your SCE who your Source I
don't reveal any sources right I've been
assured rely on what you're saying more
importantly where is the evidence in the
letters no where in the letters no doubt
I would what I would like to see these
letters because no that's where the
evidencea so you ask where the evidence
is I suggest now we now we may have
started something where we I don't to
wait I don't want to wait a thousand
years I don't want them to be locked
away in some cell somewhere I think if
you're going to accuse members of the
royal family of racism you should have
the decency and the courage to stand up
say who it was say what
they they said it I I I'm flabbergasted
so you're the victim of racism but
you're challenging the victim on having
decent being decent is that what you're
saying who the victim because I know
incredibly who the vitim incredibly
difficult the vitim don't know but do
know you're talking myal victim I do
know is ridiculous conversation Harry
and Megan so I'm apparently I'm
disrespecting some victim but you don't
know who that is you're you're
challenging what they're saying it's not
true
how do you know where's the proof well
two and a half years so so what we're
waiting for is evidence and then once
you've got the evidence and then once
you've got your evidence will you
apologize
racist once you've got your evidence
will you apologize yeah you'll apologize
to don't get me wrong if apologize to
mega mega marle produces actual evidence
of racism let's see it and if if it's
proven that King Charles or the Princess
of Wales were racist about her a baby I
will apologize to her let me tell you I
can say that with real confidence cuz it
ain't going to happen because you
haven't apologized yet for the fact that
you were wrong about the threats that
were made of on her life in terms of all
the far right groups on the terms of who
I didn't talk about that they she said
that they affected her mental health and
you said that she was lying no no I
didn't it is again you're Mis you're
misquoting me I didn't say that I said I
didn't believe she went to a senior
member of the royal household and said
she was she was feeling suicidal and
they wouldn't allow her to get help and
no evidence for that has ever been
produced and nor has that allegation
ever reappeared in the Netflix series
The Harry book all the podcast it didn't
happen so you accept she suffered from
her mental heal so you accept happened
they would have been repeated you accept
that she suffered from her mental health
you said no idea wasn't there was I all
I know is she did not go to a senior
member of the royal household saying I'm
suicidal and they said you can't get
health you've just said you don't know
about her mental health and yet you said
with assurity earlier in this
conversation that her claims about
racism about the questions of the color
of her baby they were baseless how can
you say that with a shorty when you
weren't you weren't be where's the proof
unless she was sitting there with a t
there may not be
Pro let's take a short break non let's
talk a short break and we'll come back I
mean hysteria is fine to a point it's a
bit performative you try St try and stay
on point no no no I made my point you
can have an argument without being
hysterical it's a bit pathetic just come
back after the break we're talking about
om sc's soal truth under the microscope
no just cuz you're hysterical including
the smear that you made about me in his
interview this morning that's coming up
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbias EST news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan should have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald mous man MC mous man
mous he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of Reform UK party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call H teror group is it
possible to have a rational I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they ter group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that well when it comes to uh scobby the
author of The Heart of the current royal
supposed racism Scandal there's often a
wide disparity between his version of
the truth and what the rest of us call
the actual truth in today's interview
with this morning for example who said
it again spewing more lies about me
Pierce Morgan was saying that he had no
conversations with Camila he's called
you an outright liar what would you say
to him I don't know what he says I only
go by the reporting that I have um I
also when as I was researching this and
as you see cited in the references at
the back he SP Spen a lot about his
friendship with Camila the queen so
listen I I I don't know what to make of
that but I only go by the information
that I have he's also said a lot of
things about me and the story and so on
that is also not true so I don't think I
don't find that particularly credible
and he's also said stuff about Megan in
the past as well so you know yes he also
wrote an opad this week saying that um
they should be burned a lot did I wow
that's amazing I wrote an oped piece
this week for newspapers published which
said I want Megan and Harry burned alive
that's quite something why did no one
report that how am I still here why
haven't I been
cancelled I was saying they should be
burned
alive wow
Omid here's what I actually
said I can't speak for Charles Camila
William or Kate but if two close members
of my family had spent the past few
years trashing the rest of us on global
media platforms the only way I'd want to
spend Christmas with them is if they
were human chestnuts roasting on my open
fire that's my family I'm talking about
if some of my family did what they did
I'd had them as human chestnuts on a
roaring fire where does it say I'd burn
Megan and Harry alive Omid it's just
more of Lies isn't it mate I see right
through you all right well I'm back with
my pack let me come to Paul Burl again
uh Paul my problem with Omen scobby is I
think he's just a scammer I think he
goes over all the stuff that's already
out there and he puts two and two
together and often gets five six seven
eight uh I don't think he'd know the
truth if he slapped him around his Botox
chops no well Dicky and I both have
lived with the raw family for many many
years we know all the major players we
know um for we know that there are no
racists within the royal family how
could our late Queen be racist when she
was head of the Commonwealth I mean it's
just ridiculous this conversation
because I I bet this never happened they
they must have must have dreamed up one
night I mean when they pressed that
button on the Oprah Winfrey show the
racist button they never pressed reset
and our dear late Queen went to her
grave worrying thinking there was some
upset in the house of Windsor now Harry
should be ashamed of that for upsetting
his grandmother because all of this is
just nonsense and there are no racists
in the royal family Dicky you know that
let bring in dicky I mean I actually
think I made that point also in my oped
where I said you know the the worst
thing about this for me is that Harry
spent two years allowing the racism
charge to fly around the world causing a
lot of damage especially in places like
the Commonwealth and we saw that uh and
only then after two years does he CL ify
things right and say oh I didn't mean
racism we me unconscious bias by which
time Philip and the Queen have both died
believing that from a member of their
own family their grandson that the
family had been accused of racism and it
depends who you talk to about
interpreting unconscious bias now Paul
Burl me mentioned about the royal family
not being racist the King has made it
his life's mission to unite ethnic min
minorities he goes to churches to
Cathedrals to Temples to synagogues to
mosques and he visits
communities that is his mission in life
to unite the kingdom 100% 100% there's
never been a whiff of racism about
Charles ever none so to accuse him of
racism is absolute nonsense it's
despicable and he's the one that should
be should be liiz scobby for even
suggesting I agree I think they should
sue him I really do I think that this
this this hasn't appeared in Netherlands
by chance but they won't they won't Sue
of course they won't Sue because if they
did then question you don't know that
questions would have to be answered
wouldn't they and are they prepared to
answer those questions and I'm not sure
they are and let and let's be frank
we've got this problem today because
they failed to deal with it at the time
this should have been dealt with two
years ago how it wasn't by sitting down
and thrashing it out if necessary with
two people who sold every single Mor of
private information you've exchanged
with them everything even down to Harry
acting as if the royal family never
disclose information a royal Source here
a royal Source there they are both as
bad as each other we even know that the
the which member of the royal family has
ever done to the royal family in the
monarchy what Harry and Megan have done
tell me careful what you say about the
household cuz I was part of it what we
are being told is that one household is
pitted against another household
that's what we read about who has
attacked the royal family and the
monarchy in anything like the way these
two have done as you have said as you
have said the royal family have been
through so much there was the same thing
that happened in relation to
Diana Rel which member of the royal
family in the last 100 years has
attacked the royal family and the
monarchy like these two have done for
the last three four years give me give
me a name we do live in a different area
talking is now accept I'm asking Paul a
question are you suggesting that what
Harry and Megan have said is somehow
different to what the troubles that
Diana went through at the time
absolutely how when did she ever
criticized the monarchy she suffered she
never criticized the monarchy because
she didn't feel she
had she didn't have platform Paul B will
justify this as I she was a great was a
great supporter of the monarchy she
would do nothing to harm the monarchy
what she did in her interview and what
she did in her book was damaging to her
husband correct but not to the do you
know what the irony is we have here I
mean that that that that that is I'm I'm
afraid that is a um a Nuance that is is
going to be lost on people so she so she
can speak badly about Prince Charles but
Harry can't speak badly about his father
it's his father let us let's just remind
ourselves this is about a family this is
not about an institution about the
institution he is criti part of the his
father is the King this is the problem
isn't it course it's about is talking
about his father and we are forgetting
that because what we want to do is
protect an institution you do also
talking about people who represent the
institution too sex sticky because if
people like you and peers and Paul barl
who go on and on about how much you love
the monarchy and I'm actually a
monarchist too if we really wanted to
Future proof the monarchy if PE really I
genuinely believe P that you sat there
because what you first and foremost
cared about was the monarchy you
wouldn't have started this dir tribe
mudslinging in the way that you did you
would have gently pushed them and
encouraged them to look within their own
walls to actually yes improve their
diversity quota ter of take front foot
when when relations with their foreign
realm to be clear reparation just to be
clear after your little tantrum tonight
you're telling me I should have been
calm it's a
joke you w up cuz you sat there with
your perform going to throw a little
toddler T like you did earlier
don't get to me about being calm me can
I just respond to the question about
what do you do because there are there
are lots of people who have the
allegation of racism thrown against them
and I appreciate I really do that it is
hard to have that allegation thrown
against you because it is hard to defend
P you know that you've had the
allegation thrown at you enough time
when you watch incred when you watch
back what what they said on Oprah yeah
there's no ambiguity that they were
accusing them of being racist is there
if it if it was me if it was me saying
that I would be in my heart worried that
I was suffering from racism right thank
you I would that that's my point okay
and then they downgraded it two years
later to unconscious bias but but but
actually you agree with me cut me off as
Dicky has said unconscious bias has a
definition that can also include racism
unconscious bias
is pi thinks it's all baseless CU Pi
knows better we're going to take a break
come back with a new pack fortunately uh
no offense to you Dicky or To You Paul
um thoroughly enjoyed having you two on
tonight next will the resurfacing of
these racism allegations damage the
royal family on a global stage or would
it clear their reputations is what I
believe will now happen debating that
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
you know what I love about for today we
do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any all will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear and O in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of P there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
un Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a Liv if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to
call is it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV
welcome back the rawal race ra has been
reignited by the claims inen scob book
my decision to announce the names behind
the claims has made headlines around the
world from India to New Zealand and the
United States where of course Harry and
Megan reside the British royal family is
a global brand which is precisely why
Megan's original claims were so damaging
now we know much more about the
allegations anyone really still believe
them would join me discuss this artv
contributor Esther Kracker political
journalist AA stina and from New York
the talk TV presenter Trisha Godard
right Esther we just had a rather
animated debate about all this which I
thought was a little unnecessarily uh
over the top um what's your view about
all this I I think the people's in uh
well desire to believe whether the royal
family are racist or not stems from what
they originally feel about the royal
family to begin with if you think the
royal family is an Antiquated
institution that's you know rooted in
white supremacy of course you're happy
to believe that you know the racism
allegations were true if you're a Storch
monarchist you're like they can never do
any wrong and for the rest of us we're
thinking okay what's the evidence
because at the end of the day the
Monarch is still our head of state and
it it's important that they obviously
not bigoted individuals and that's where
I that's the camp that I fall in at the
end of the day I don't see any evidence
of racism I've said this before I I I
I'm from a ghanian family if I was
having a child with someone who wasn't
of my race my my family would have
conversation about what the child would
look like in a jovial way and I think
there was an element of bad faith of
course it if it was that there's nothing
wrong with that anyway but we don't know
that we don't no
come on like come on if there's if
there's been a conversation behind doors
about you know the child's skin color
obviously me this Megan's mother was in
an interracial relationship which is
Megan which is Megan is the product of
Megan's family would have undoubtedly
had conversation oh what's Megan going
to look like I wonder what she's going
to look like since your husband is wife
would that have made her family racist
do you
think answer that would that have made
Megan can I answer it with this point
that do you not think that that is
skewed that is skewed by your now with
the British Monarchy
and they are they are that child to dark
to be in the Royal you don't believe
that you don't believe that was the way
that conversation I was there none of us
were does any it makes sense that
Charles and Kate of all people right Ty
dedicated their public life to actually
being completely inclusive never said a
racist word in their lives that suddenly
they're going to be saying I hope it's
not too
Brown let me answer that let me answer
that I'm going to be extremely careful
with what I say because of Lial law but
I do think that there is some racism in
the royal family not necessarily hang on
I'm not going to put that on any
individual but yes I could imagine a
world that's where there are all right
let me bring in Trisha who's been
waiting patiently Trisha look let's try
and have a you know sensible
conversation about this you know I've
just watched the Sussex who backtrack
backtrack backtrack it's gone from
racism and we heard it from their own
mouths on Oprah to unconscious bias no
one's produced a shred of actual
evidence here you know I'm sorry I'm
calling calling it's
nonsense you know Pierce I had a really
interesting conversation with my kids
who are
biracial and they have people in their
family extended family who have um used
words or little phrases that anybody
else would just think H doesn't matter
but because of their personal
experiences they've had to sit down with
those people and say you know this term
is not acceptable I know you think it's
a joke you I know you think we should
light lighten up but within our family
it it hurts it's painful because of our
experience now if I can say that there's
somebody out you know people in our
family have had those conversations and
yes they're hurtful where if somebody
comes along after the fact two years
down the track and makes it all public
and it blows it up it becomes even more
painful and people you when you talk
about backtracking can I rephrase that
sometimes we can learn I've watched you
grow if I can put it that way we're
never too old to learn I've seen you
learn as I have with lots of different
things around Israel Gaza we learn we
learn we learn what if let me just put
this to you what if since they initially
came out with what an American sees as
racism and I do think there are cultural
differences just because we're all brown
doesn't mean to say we all think the
same but what if from there they've
learned earned and it it's not so much
as backpedaling cuz I'm just thinking of
family members within ours it's like oh
okay yeah I shouldn't have said that or
oh maybe they weren't being they didn't
mean to be racist but they didn't even
realize they're so used to being casual
about it they didn't realize it would
hurt us but I have to say about omed
scobby he is like the uncle who turns up
two years after the fact at a Christmas
party and shows off the the the messages
you that you texted them 2 years ago
when you were drunk I mean when I heard
this book was coming out can I say this
are we uncensored yes should I be honest
what I really thought yes I thought what
the [__] I'm sorry sorry I was like oh
for I'd like to apologize to any viewers
offended but we are unsensed and you
know what that's exactly what I thought
too I I just haven't said it
yet it's like the horse has bolted it's
at the knacked yard it's glue and we I
mean I don't believe anything was done
with Mal intent I think there was a lot
of misunderstanding I do think there are
terms and questions and it depends where
you're brought up but if there are
questions and people are talking about
what a baby's color are for one family
it may be done in a light-hearted way in
another family if there's already
friction it might
be Twist of the knif all right before we
go to the break I want to play a clip of
Prince Harry on the St Co be
show the ginger Jean is a strong one
look at that both of them both of them
dispenser Gene is very very strong I
actually really genuinely thought at the
beginning of my relationship that should
this go the distance and then we have
kids there's no way the ginger Jee will
stand up to my wife's jeans but I was
wrong wow isn't he speculating about the
skin color of his baby wow uh let's take
a break we'll come back and debate that
after the
break
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tor love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella Bradman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do I'm going
you're going to Res course I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on that
I labeled you douche of the day not sure
if you've been a lead athlete before but
it's a problem never seen an Australian
Suk like curios you responded eat a
sometimes you are a bit you're a sicker
nothing you say can me appears nothing
May about take it to the courts and we
sort it out once and for
[Music]
all little treat for you tomorrow night
and a little extra here's Morgan on
senstive with Nick curios for the hour
from 8: to 9:00 p.m. tomorrow night it
is a cracker it's a proper like tennis
match serve volley serve volley smash
serve volley Smash and so on for the
hour welcome back I got Esther AA and
Trisha still with me of course so Esther
Where Do We Go From Here see I I kind of
feel from the moment I reveal these
names it would trigger a process which
would actually just Lance this boil once
and for all it would all get out there
how do you think the Sussex are going to
respond well I think they're going to
regret how they went about it because I
do think this this is all just a play of
bad faith actually this the whole
interaction that happened the British
public have had like 3 years to to to
ruminate over this to think is it
possible actually of all the things that
are coming out because they did multiple
interviews spare came out where he
didn't even mention it that's the weird
thing to me it sounds like much to do
about nothing so I think most people are
like and now that the names are out it's
like oh come on no it's I did think it's
quite extraordinary that you you launch
this bombshell you brand the family
races quite clearly we've played the
clips back and then you don't mention it
in a 400 page book you don't mention it
in your six-part Netflix series about
your life you don't mention it in the
Spotify poker none of it all just just
just got airbrushed but how could they
mention it I mean it's quite easy no but
come on if you literally did an
interview with opr about it l of Power
are skewed against them aren't they they
can't come out and call the King a
racist they can't do that they they they
can they can detail the interaction and
they can detail the reaction interaction
and actually name very much at the
behest of the royal family so as you
said as you said they trade under their
titles they trade under their names and
they also do need certain things from
the royal family they also had you know
the queen would have still been alive
when that Oprah interview went out and
they knew that they couldn't completely
blow all of their relationship with the
family but clearly this has had some
very significant effect on Megan and we
are looking at a woman who is claiming
racism and I just think that we should
as the public take that seriously yeah
I'm afraid we've taken it seriously and
it turned out that two years later they
say oh we didn't mean to say racism
literally har said we didn't mean to say
racis the Press said that he's such a
liar let's go back to Trisha um you it
my issue with this treas is that every
day people are exposed to real racism
real damaging racial Injustice racial
inequality there's all sorts hang on you
can talk about and and people often find
it easier to understand somebody being
beaten up or hit as I have been purely
because of my skin color as a child okay
but there's microaggressions there's
lots of little things that weigh up or
and affect people's mental health and
again if you come from a culture if you
come from a world like Hollywood where
you're protected from all of that where
half the things that get written in
British papers aren't allowed to be
printed in US newspapers you come in for
a bit of a shock when you come up
against the British culture and the
British Black Culture so one person's
racism if you feel it you know it's like
the old conversations we had 10 15 years
ago about when is it really sexual
assault no it wasn't really she took it
the wrong way and I agree totally when
you say if somebody says they are hurt
by something that has racial undertones
it it doesn't matter what you think it
matters what the person who knows the
details which we don't if they have been
hurt by it they've been hurt by it why
do we have to have a discussion about it
end off because I think Happ different
ways
and doesn't matter really what you think
does it CU it doesn't really well
actually it does there somebody who pays
their wages somebody who pays the Royal
Family's wages it does not anymore well
not those anymore but I did I did it the
time but hang on hang on but appears
I've been paying up until
2015 money back to people who enslaved
my my forbears so I mean we all pay for
something we might necessar not
necessarily believe in 100% but you know
it doesn't matter if it hurt her it hurt
her I think he's also hurt King Charles
and uh and Kate I mean that's the point
I don't think so of course it has I
don't think so what could be a worse
offense why did you rush okay so one of
the the main reasons that I applauded
you for naming them yesterday was
because I think the rest of the British
media didn't do it because they would
like to keep some form of relationship
with them and they were frightened about
what the repercussions would be but now
you're sitting here defending Char and
you weren't there for that conversation
why aren't you defending seen no proof
it happen from perspec come on here I
agree you know what we got to leave it
there you're invited King Charles the
Princess of Wales Megan marle Prince
Harry you're all invited come on at the
same time for a gigantic bear Morgan
uncensored that's it for tonight thank
you to my brilliant pack whatever you're
up to keep it on sens
[Music]
good we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
they have made a statement condemning
Hamas we expect to see the crown revisit
Harry's anti-semitic Halloween costume
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming round the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashak has done the question now
is what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swearing off in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a f or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners Do you have a a
message for Sadi Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking Li if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan should have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz Phil do you think